has had her appeal dismissed by the
court behind me Mr Justice J has decided
to dismiss her Appeal on all counts this
was an appeal to try and regain her
British citizenship it means that Shamir
begum will not be able to win back her
British passport it leaves her now very
much in limbo this was the 15 year old
school girl but left East London Bound
for is controlled Syria in 2015 this
appeal dismissal side essentially with
the government's argument that yes even
if somebody has been brainwashed or has
gone to Syria they still pose a national
threat risk and a risk to National
Security this dismisses the arguments
that were put forward by Ms bagan's
lawyers that she was a victim of child
trafficking but it remains that ever
since her British citizenship was
stripped from her in 2019 she has a
repeat try to win it back and it Remains
the case that she will not become a
British citizen once again this was her
latest attempt though at the ruling
today Mr Justice J spoke very briefly
that was a written ruling that was read
out in court one behind me that that
appeal has indeed been dismissed that's
after him Gathering evidence and
testimony both from the government and
from Miss begum's family this all
started of course in 2019 when she moved
him at the time was nine months pregnant
and when she was found in Assyrian
detention camp where she will remain
what does this mean for her future
though those other questions that will
be posed it leaves her with little
option the question is where does she go
from here does she try to gain
citizenship elsewhere such as Bangladesh
where her family originally from but it
certainly seems like the UK is firmly
off the cards